[Musique]
le dossier est au coeur des
manifestations qui ont fait plus de 300
blessés ces derniers jours la justice
israélienne décide de reporter
l'audience sur le sort de familles
palestiniennes elles sont menacés
d'éviction par des colons israéliens à
jérusalem-est
l'audience était prévue demain une
nouvelle date devrait être annoncée dans
les 30 jours
[Musique]
la violence en colombie qui dénoncé par
la diaspora en france en espagne en
argentine ou encore au chili elle se
jouant à la lutte c'est apporte son
soutien au peuple colombien alors que de
nouvelles manifestations ont eu lieu
hier à cali les protestataires
la paix ces dix derniers jours la
répression des rassemblements
antigouvernementaux a fait 26 morts et
plus de 800 blessés
[Musique]
c'est notre marque le jour de la
victoire en russie victoire sur
l'allemagne nazie lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale un gigantesque défilé
militaire a rassemblé à moscou plus de
douze mille militaires et 190 véhicules
dans son discours vladimir poutine a
salué une date historique ajoutant qu'il
n'y aurait ni pardon ni excuse pour ceux
qui envisagent un nouveau détour
d'agression
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france l'audience
devait se tenir demain dans un climat de
vives tensions la justice israélienne a
donc annoncé cet après midi la reporter
audience sur le sort de familles
palestiniennes menacés d'éviction par
des colons israéliens à jérusalem-est
audience qui est au coeur des
manifestations
elles ont fait plus de 300 blessés ces
derniers jours françois tessier beach
l'apport de damas transformée en champ
de bataille ce samedi soir de nouveaux
heurts entre manifestants palestiniens
et policiers israéliens ont fait une
centaine de blessés selon le croissant
rouge palestinien
la police israélienne fait de son côté
état de dix sept policiers blessés et
neuf arrestations
manifestations également dans les
territoires palestiniens comme ici près
d'un poste de contrôle de l'armée
israélienne au sud de naplouse
c'est un massacre contre toute la nation
islamique et pas seulement contre le
peuple palestinien
nous ne laisserons pas jérusalem
tranquille même si nous résistons
jusqu'à la mort et même si nous mourrons
les uns après les autres
un week-end sous haute tension la veille
sur l'esplanade des mosquées
des affrontements entre forces de
l'ordre israéliennes et fidèles
palestiniens réunis pour l'iftar le
repas de rupture du jeûne du ramadan
avait fait plus de 200 blessés
le premier ministre israëlien promet ce
dimanche de préserver la liberté de
culte mais prévient contre d'éventuelles
émeutes
ces derniers jours nous avons été
témoins de violentes émeutes à jérusalem
influencé par des groupes incitatif
nous ne permettrons à aucun élément
radical de compromettre le calme à
jérusalem nous ferons respecter la loi
et l'ordre avec fermeté et
responsabilité
si nous continueront d'assurer la
liberté de culte mais n'autoriserons pas
des émeutes violentes
en même temps je dis aux organisations
terroristes qu'israël réagira avec force
à toute acte d'agression provenant de la
bande de gaza des tensions croissantes
alors que la justice israélienne devait
se prononcer ce lundi sur le sort de
familles palestiniennes menacés
d'éviction par des colons israéliens à
jérusalem-est une audience finalement
reporté ce dimanche une nouvelle date
doit être annoncée dans les 30 prochains
jours
dans un communiqué publié dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche l'organisation des
nations unies l'union européenne les
états-unis la russie ont exprimé leur
inquiétude
nous appelons les autorités israéliennes
à faire preuve de retenue et à éviter
des mesures qui pourraient entraîner une
escalade de la situation durant cette
période deux jours saints musulmans
ce dimanche matin le calme est revenu
aux alentours de la porte de damas
un calme précaire le hamas a appelé les
palestiniens restés sur l'esplanade
jusqu'à jeudi jour devant marquer la fin
du ramadan
[Musique]
onzième jour de manifestations en
colombie fier le président even doc et a
demandé la levée des barrages routiers
ils se sont multipliés ces derniers
jours comme les rassemblements
violemment réprimées au moins 26 morts
et plus de 800 blessés alors solidarité
de nombreuses manifestations ont été
organisées par la diaspora colombienne
un sujet signé françois disque est vite
hélas madjed un appel à l'aide ce samedi
plusieurs centaines de ressortissants
colombiens se sont rassemblés place de
la république à paris pour manifester
leur solidarité avec les protestations
antigouvernementales sévèrement réprimée
en colombie on est là bas simplement
parce qu'ils avaient peuple il ya fans
parce que les peuples il est abandonné
parce qu'elle est pauline a marre des sa
situation
tu devrais formation à la santé pour
privatiser la santé des internats
militarisation de la protest ça c'est
innaceptable ont pu pas dit ça après les
convives il ya une crise qui a vraiment
augmenté la pauvreté en colombie et le
gouvernement a essayé de solutionner ces
crises parmi des impôts aux plus pauvres
à tous la consommation des produits
connaître qui on consomme tous les jours
comme les tomates des oignons etc
en plus de ça il y avait aussi des
centres pour les salaires de la classe
moyenne de la cid de deauville de bogota
et tout ça qui seraient à peu près 500
dollars par mois
donc les gens sont exposés dans la roue
et son copain c'est à dire on ne va pas
accepter ça et la police a commencé à
tous et des gens n'importe qui
manifestations également en espagne où
ils étaient plusieurs milliers à madrid
avec 145 mille personnes de nationalité
colombienne
c'est la plus importante diaspora à
l'extérieur du continent américain
nous lançons à la communauté
internationale aux organisations
internationales
un appel à l'aide parce que les vidéos
ne mentent pas parce que ce n'est pas un
discours de haine
c'est que notre colombie celle que nous
disons et mettant est en train d'être
saignés devant nos yeux et aux yeux du
monde et nous ne resterons pas
silencieux des rassemblements également
en argentine ou une fausse scène de
funérailles d'un manifestant tué et
jouer devant l'ambassade colombienne à
buenos aires ou encore au chili à
santiago où des bougies sont déposés
devant le consulat de colombie
[Applaudissements]
l'organisation des nations unies l'union
européenne et les etats unis ont dénoncé
ces derniers jours l'usagé
disproportionné de la force par la
police colombienne une police victime
d'une campagne de stigmatisation selon
le ministre colombien de la défense
depuis le 28 avril
les manifestations contre un projet de
réforme fiscale retirés depuis par le
président colombien est vent debout
quais sont sévèrement réprimées selon le
bilan communiqué par le gouvernement
vingt-six personnes sont mortes et plus
de 1500 ont été blessés tandis que 90
personnes sont toujours portées
disparues un des milliers de
manifestants à paris ce dimanche pour
dénoncer le manque d'envergure de la loi
climat elle a été adoptée mardi à
l'assemblée écologistes partis de gauche
et syndicats dénoncent un rendez vous
raté au moment où des doutes aussi se
font jour sur un référendum pour
inscrire dans la constitution la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique
des rassemblements dans plus de 150
villes à travers le pays à l'initiative
du collectif plus jamais ça écoutez ces
quelques manifestants au micro de bassem
chab y danser mobilisés aujourd'hui pour
demander une vraie loi climat on s'était
déjà mobilisé le 28 mars pour la même
chose on est quasiment un mois plus tard
et il sait absolument pas à faire passer
si ce n'est que la loi est encore plus
pourri que ce qu'elle était au début il
ya eu des propositions de la convention
citoyenne paul climat qui était à la
hauteur des enjeux climatiques et le
projet de loi final qui est en train
d'être votée qui va être votée au sénat
n'est pas du tout à la hauteur là dans
l'état on va juste faire une petite loi
qui va permettre de petites choses mais
qui permettront pas du tout de faire
face à la crise climatique et demain en
fait ça va être un monde un peu
dégueulasse qu'on va laisser à nos
enfants
du coup on se mobilise aujourd'hui pour
balade demandé aux hauts faits la
majorité principalement de prendre ses
responsabilités de proposer une vraie
loi climat est d'aller plus loin que je
de la simple communication comme comme
il aime tant faire et on voit que la loi
les propositions qu'ils en fait on était
toutes détricoté par les différents
lobbys par voilà tous que tous les
enjeux tout
tous les intérêts des entreprises qui
était défendu par tardif a défendu par
les entreprises et renault est là pour
dire non on est d'accord avec ses 150 on
vous rappelle que on veut leur faire
confiance on veut écouter ce qu'ils
avaient à dire et on veut une loi qui
est plus ambitieuse par rapport à ce
qu'ils proposaient parce que là ça ne
suffira pas là on va juste
collectivement droit dans le mur quand
il est passé complètement à côté parce
que son logiciel à lui s'est toujours
l'économie comme avant et au nom de
l'économie il est prêt à tout sacrifier
il ne croit pas réellement conséquence
de l'environnement des problèmes
environnementaux
or les problèmes environnementaux c'est
le prémice des problèmes sociaux qui
vont aller avec forcément parce que dans
tous ces cas là la crise sociale elle et
elle suit où elle précède même la crise
écologique
c'est toujours les plus pauvres qui s'en
sortira lé moins qu'ils en sortiront les
moins bien et donc c'est vraiment
important à la fois socialement mais
également démocratiquement d'être dans
ces combats pour essayer de faire en
sorte que le gouvernement nous entende
et depuis le mois de mai l'un depuis le
mois de mars la loi climat a fait
l'objet de plus de 100 heures de débat
fera bon d'être un adopter donc mardi à
l'assemblée nationale le texte est
désormais attendue au sénat courant juin
retour en images sur ce marathon
législatif avec rob actuelle le mardi 4
mai 2021 l'assemblée nationale adopte en
première lecture le projet de loi climat
et résilience
le texte de loi a été voté au terme d'un
marathon législatif de trois semaines et
110 heures de débats landais record sous
la vème république
le gouvernement présente la loi climat
et résilience comme la continuité du
travail engagé lors de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat
le 21 juin en 2020 ce encore en neuf
propositions sont remises à emmanuel
macron qui s'était engagé à mettre en
application tout ce qui sortirait de
cette expérience
le projet du gouvernement à conserver
certaines mesures phares comme la
création d'un des guides écocide la
suppression des lignes aériennes
intérieures lorsqu'un trajets de train
de moins de deux heures et demie est
possible ou la régulation de certaines
publicités pour des produits polluants
rapidement de nombreuses voix se sont
élevées contre ce projet de loi
des dizaines de ng syndicats et partis
dénoncent le manque d'ambition de la loi
climat selon une enquête du média
reporter seulement quinze propositions
retenues lors de la convention citoyenne
ont été reprises sans modification dans
le projet de loi
toujours selon cette enquête plus de la
moitié des propositions de la convention
citoyenne ont tout simplement été
écartée le 4 mai avant l'adoption du
texte
une dizaine de militantes d'extinction
rébellion se sont enchaînés aux grilles
de l'assemblée pour fustiger le projet
de loi qu'il juge trop faibles
une action relayée dans l'hémicycle par
adrien catane 1 ce député de la france
insoumise
un hommage national sera rendu mardi
chez au brigadier éric masson à la
préfecture de vaucluse elle sera
présidée par le premier ministre jean
castex
cet après midi ce sont ses collègues
policiers qui se sont rassemblés devant
l'hôtel de police d'avignon rejoints par
de très nombreux avignonnais les
syndicats de policiers avaient appelé à
ce rassemblement pour se recueillir et
pour honorer sa mémoire
éric masson a été tué mercredi lors
d'une intervention contre 1,1 point de
trafic de drogue
le tireur et son complice ont pris la
fuite ils sont toujours activement
recherchés
le 9 mai journée de l'europe l'un des
symboles de l'union européenne qui
célèbre la déclaration schuman de 1950
un texte fondateur il ya 71 ans robert
schuman ministre français des affaires
étrangères proposait alors dans un
discours à paris la création d'une
institution regroupant plusieurs pays de
l'europe et qui rassemblerait généré
gérerait en commun la production du
charbon et de l'acier pour l'occasion
emmanuel macron s'est rendu à strasbourg
aux côtés de ses homologues européens le
chef de l'état français et à donner le
coup d'envoi de la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe
une consultation citoyenne qui rendra
ses conclusions au printemps 2022 au
moment où la france prendra la
présidence tournante de l'ue eux
emmanuel macron qui appelle à une
renaissance européenne en écoute qu'on
s'est divisée à chaque fois que nous
étions dépendants à chaque fois que nous
étions confrontés à un risque dont la
réponse n'était pas dans nos mains nous
avons réalisé que la souveraineté c'est
aussi la capacité à produire aujourd'hui
et demain et donc je ne crois pas que
nous aurons une europe qui puisse être à
la hauteur de son histoire et ses
valeurs
si elle ne prend pas plus conscience que
dans les années 80 90 et 2000 du fait
que nous ne sommes pas simplement un
grand marché de consommateurs
ouvert à tous les vents nous le sommes
aussi
mais nous devons redevenir des
producteurs nous devons redevenir une
communauté de grands chercheurs de
grands créateurs de grands artistes
de grands industriels parce que produire
créer sur notre sol c'est garantir notre
souveraineté
la protection de notre modèle de nos
valeurs et cette souveraineté culturelle
académiques industriels de recherche est
absolument essentiel est il selon pierre
emmanuel un thomann fondateur de re
continent et professeur en géopolitique
le débat sur l'avenir de l'union
européenne est important mais il est
tronqué écouter les promoteurs de
l'intégration européenne mais du
fédéralisme européen
ils veulent absolument imposer leur
modèle de projet européen qui est basé
sur des paradigmes je dirais ancré dans
le siècle dernier obsolètes par rapport
au monde multipolaire aujourd'hui et
d'où d'ailleurs la désaffection des
peuples par rapport à ce projet européen
et je pense qu'il est important d'avoir
une alliance entre états européens dans
ce monde multipolaire mais une europe
géopolitique et c'est les débats qui
sont organisées au niveau institutionnel
quand cette conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe ne va pas changer la crise
fondamentale la crise des fondements de
l'europe parce que les européistes vont
essayer de toujours de promouvoir en
fait non pas l'europe civilisationnel
mais une une europe des normes qu'on
appelle l'europe des valeurs mais ce
sont des normes de gouvernement en fait
à la tunisie se tourner vers le fonds
monétaire international
le ministre tunisien des finances s'est
rendue à washington pour négocier
nouveaux prêts le quatrième en dix ans
depuis la révolution de 2011 le pays est
empêtré dans une inquiétante crise
économique alors quel plan daide et
quelles concessions
on va cela avec un bassin chebbi
économie en déroute finances publiques
aux abois tunis s'apprête à demander son
quatrième prêts au fonds monétaire
international
depuis la révolution de 2011 un prêt non
sans conséquences pour le pays qui devra
s'accompagner de réformes drastiques de
privatisation de licenciements massifs
dans la fonction publique que lui jette
était le principal syndicat tunisien
compte bien négocié les nombreux plans
des d'internationaux accordé depuis plus
de dix ans n'ont pas
suffi à redresser le pays qui souffre
toujours d'un sous développement
chronique avec un chômage qui touche
près de 2 actif sur cinq
une fois n'est pas coutume c'est auprès
du fmi et pour la quatrième fois que
tunis se tourne après avoir obtenu de
l'institution de bretton woods une
facilité de paiement de 616 millions
d'euros l'an dernier
la tunisie souhaite aujourd'hui une
rallonge assez importante 3 5 milliards
d'euros remboursables sur trois ans
objectif boucler son budget et sortir de
la spirale du surendettement
je peux confirmer que les équipes du
fonds ont rencontré les autorités
tunisiennes plus tôt cette semaine et
celle ci ont fait part de leur programme
de réformes économiques
nous sommes prêts à aider la tunisie le
peuple tunisien à lutter contre l'impact
de la crise à progresser vers une
reprise inclusive et à restaurer des
finances viable à washington jusqu'au 9
mai la délégation tunisienne va devoir
apporter des garanties mais surtout se
plier aux doléances du fmi notamment en
matière de réforme condition sinequanone
auprès l'une des mesures phares et de
remplacer les subventions des prix des
produits de première nécessité comme le
pain par des aides directes aux familles
un projet qui n'est pas du goût des
tunisiens qui reproche au gouvernement
de s'attaquer aux acquis de la
population autres projets et réformer le
secteur public
et c'est bien là le coeur de la gangrène
tunisienne il faut savoir qu'en tunisie
les dépenses liées à la fonction
publique ont toujours été
disproportionnée avec un nombre de
fonctionnaires bien trop élevé par
rapport au nombre d'habitants et aux
besoins du pays se dépense représente
plus de 17 % du pib chez l'un des
niveaux les plus élevés au monde
à titre de comparaison la france elle
consacre 13 % de son pib aux salaires de
ses administrations pour ce faire
quelques pistes sont à l'étude départs à
la retraite anticipés elle travaille à
temps partiel restructuration des
entreprises publiques lourdement
endettés comme la compagnie aérienne
nationale tunisair ou encore la steg
société tunisienne d'électricité et de
gaz
tunis entend contenir la masse salariale
autour de 15 % du pib en 2022 contre
17,4 pour cent du pib en 2020 selon un
rapport obtenu par l' agence
france-presse
avec un déficit budgétaire qui a triplé
en 2021
5 % du pib et une dette à 100% du pib
national
la tunisie n'a d'autre choix que de se
tourner vers les instances
internationales quitte à se plier à des
conditions drastiques sans réelle marge
de manoeuvre surendetté à genoux et au
bord de la banqueroute le pays semble
n'avoir plus d'autre choix que de se
plier aux exigences du fonds monétaire
international pour peut-être espérer
sortir de cette crise économique et
sociale sans précédent à la russie rend
hommage aux soldats soviétiques qui ont
payé un lourd tribut lors de la seconde
guerre mondiale mais aussi aux millions
de civils qui ont contribué à la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie
76e anniversaire cette année un
gigantesque défilé militaire était
organisée pour l'occasion à moscou lors
de son discours ou vladimir poutine a
salué une date historique
ajoutons qu'il n'y aurait ni pardon ni
excuse pour ceux qui envisagent à
nouveau des plombs d'agression je vous
propose d'écouter le président mais
l'histoire nous oblige à tirer des
conclusions à tirer des leçons mais nous
constatons que tous ne sont pas prêts à
tirer cette conclusion et qui veulent en
à nouveau défendre cette idéologie on
voit la résurgence de d'extrémistes et
d'adeptes de cette idéologie de volonté
voit cette volonté de réécrire
l'histoire et les centaines de milliers
de morts sont ignorés par ce genre
aujourd'hui on sait que chaque famille
garde la mémoire de ceux qui sont ici
ont combattu la russie continue à
défendre le droit international et nous
continuerons à défendre en même temps il
ose un terreau nos intérêts nationaux
un discours d'importance de par l'accent
mis sur la vigilance que devrait porter
la communauté internationale face à la
résurgence de discours un néo nazi en
ukraine c'est ce que nous dit et gilles
rémy cet homme d'affaires qui a su
tisser un lien particulier avec la
russie tout au long de sa carrière
ce qui est très douloureux non seulement
pour les ukrainiens mais pour les russes
c'est cette se laisser faire du régime
au pouvoir en ukraine en verre ce qui
est la résurgence de d'une collaboration
et d'asie j'étais très très choqué de
voir que la dernière manifestation néo
nazis en faveur du régiment des waffen
ss galicie qui a eu à kiev ya quinze
jours n'a pas du tout été évoquée par là
par la presse française et occidentale
en général parce que ça gêne parce que
là l'ukraine et est notre alliée dans
une dans un engin dans un combat pour
affaiblir la la la russie c'est un
calcul stupide à mon sens mais on ne
doit pas laisser passer des choses comme
ça tous les russes savent très bien ça
paraisse dans l'est dans l'est dans les
journaux télévisés ce qui se passe en
ukraine alors ce n'est pas là le pays
entier qui risque de tomber dans la dans
un vidéo et nazisme mais c'est
insupportable
insupportable que dd monument sera érigé
à d'anciens collaborateurs nazis
et puis c'est insupportable que par
exemple le rôle de 6e 16e anniversaire
du massacre d'odessa qu'en plus de 40
personnes ont été brûlées vives à la
maison des syndicats où est la digne à
sion étrangères l'a dit nation et la
nuit parti en ukraine et en russie ont
connu pour son architecture et sa
ponctualité le métro moscovite mais
aussi pour avoir servi d'abris anti
aériens pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale lorsque l'aviation allemande a
bombardé la capitale russe des milliers
de personnes s'y sont réfugiés une
deuxième vie sous terre a alors commencé
vers 1 gossmann le métro de moscou
dans le monde entier pour sa beauté sans
parler de sa fiabilité et sa vitesse par
dans la seconde guerre mondiale sept
nervis artistique à sauver des vies
le 22 juillet 1941 en mois après le
début de la guerre moscou faisait face à
sa première attaque aérienne pendant les
bombardements jusqu'à un demi millions
de moscovites ont trouvé refuge dans le
métro aleph tino baranova âgé de 9 ans à
l'époque était avec sa soeur et sa mère
parmi ceux qui descendait sous terre
presque chaque soir quand il y avait une
alerte aérienne on nous faisait
descendre dans le métro
et donc nous descendions dans le métro
il y avait une rame à quai seules les
femmes enceintes et celles avec des
bébés y étaient admises ou les personnes
âgées très faible il renie midi qui met
tous les autres on les faisait descendre
par un escalier en bois devant la
première voiture dans le tunnel pendant
tout le bombardement rester dans le
tunnel il n'y avait nulle part où
s'asseoir lors d'une nuit de
bombardement particulièrement intensifs
il y avait trop de monde dans les
tunnels et alex steen a failli
suffoquait un vieil homme a dit mr
soulevé vos enfants au dessus de vos
têtes et faites-les passait sur le quai
pour qu'il ne crève pas ici c'est ce
qu'il a dit parce qu'il n'y avait pas
d'air vous pouvez imaginer ça nous
étions petits et nous les petits on nous
a soulevé fait passer pour nous remettre
sur le pied staub nos plats pour moi b c
et d et une fois le raid aérien terminé
les parents se sont levés et ont
récupéré leurs enfants c'est arrivé une
seule fois nous sommes restés debout
pendant tout le bombardement en
attendant l'annoncé fin de l' alerte fin
de l' alerte le raid aérien est terminée
pendant la guerre le métro servait de
transport et de refuge
mais on y trouvait aussi en hôpital une
bibliothèque et même un cinéma
pourquoi avons-nous un nombre
relativement bas de victimes et de morts
parce que dans les premiers mois de la
guerre beaucoup de travail a été
accomplie pour préparer des abris pour
la population le métro de moscou est
célèbre pour son ordre et sa propreté
les stations étaient nettoyés et
désinfectés tous les jours on se prépare
est vraiment pour faire tout ça
le métro cessé de fonctionner en tant qu
abri à 5 heures du matin mais certains
passagers restés pour aider le personnel
de la station et faire le ménage pendant
la guerre tout le pays a vécu un même
élan le front et l'arrière formé en tout
tout le monde littéralement tout le
monde essayait de faire tout son
possible et encore plus pour la victoire
au front bien sûr c'était dur mais à
l'arrière les gens travailler et ne
quittait pas leur poste pendant 10 12
heures voire plus non pas parce que
quelqu'un les forcer à le faire mais
parce qu'il voulait vraiment faire plus
pourvu qu'il n'y ait plus de guerre
répète souvent les anciens combattants
pourvu que ces murs voix seulement les
passagers et pas de réfugiés il se joue
de la victoire soviétique sur
l'allemagne nazie a été célébré en
russie mais aussi un peu partout dans le
monde à berlin les commémorations se
sont déroulés au mémorial soviétique de
tiergarten un cortège militaire aux
couleurs de la russie a défilé en syrie
commémoration également dans la
forteresse 1 de brest litovsk en
biélorussie enfin bbc en géorgie des
dépôts de gerbes de fleurs avec park
devant le mémorial de la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est la fin de cette édition
prochain point sur l'actu dans une
trentaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences